everyone its Jonah here so I'm going to
share with you five foods that I eat on
a daily basis and why you should also
add them to your diet so when I get up
first thing in the morning I like to
make myself a cup of warm lemon drink
and drink it on an empty stomach if
you're someone who struggles with
constipation or bloating drink lemon
water first thing in the morning if you
prefer you can sweeten it with a little
bit of maple syrup or honey the
hydrophobicity content will also boosts
your immune system so that you won't be
falling you every so often I like to
have overnight oats for my breakfast
oats are extremely high in fiber low in
fat and calories it is really filling
just having half a cup of oats topped
with fruits nuts and seeds or Kimmi
satisfies until lunchtime unlike a heavy
breakfast high in sugar and fat which
may leave you feeling bloated and
sluggish oats are very soothing to the
tummy it's filling yet light and keep
your tummy happy when I go to work I
like to make two large bottles of
chilled green tea filled with chia seeds
and I'll sip it throughout the day while
at work green tea is known as a superb
fat burner and it also helps to reduce
bloating if I'm having a stressful day
sipping on green tea helps keep me calm
as focused throughout the day just it's
a high in fiber and expand in the
stomach when eaten which keeps me
feeling fuller for longer so this
combination of green tea and chia seeds
provide me with sustained energy
throughout the day and curbs my hunger
and my final must eat superfood on a
daily basis encourages berries the
world's most nutrient dense fruit this
tiny fruit is also known as the key to
eternal youth I like to literally add
this into everything I eat and drink
into my oatmeal
soups drinks or just have it on its own
so these are my top must-haves
superfoods on a daily basis as I'm into
your diet and gain the same benefits
I've been getting all these years what
are your must-haves a daily superfood
let me know in the comments below
like this video share it and subscribe
to my youtube channel for a lot more
exciting videos every week don't forget
to also turn on your notification button
so that you will get notified every time
I upload a new video or the best